[Music]
hey you guys happy sunday yeah it's
labor day weekend
we watched this one last night it's not
the first time i've seen it i saw it a
long time ago it's just in the
background of a [ __ ] day room and
[ __ ] [ __ ] where i was working one
time and watched little bits of it here
and there and
it looked cool then uh saw it again and
uh realized it was a steven spielberg
flick that had [ __ ] tom cruise in it
i had totally forgotten that this was a
stephen spielberg movie isn't that funny
yeah it's all futuristic you know
[ __ ] it back in the day
and um the story it holds up the story
kind of holds up in terms of
entertainment value
the technology doesn't but
it's kind of it's kind of a trip where
just at this i think this is only what
2002 maybe 2002 2002
20 years
man went by fast huh
and look how much look how much people's
um
concept of the future has changed
because this is supposed to be going on
in 2050 2054 yeah yeah well let's see
okay
and
and they still have newspapers
although they were like all like moving
around
well it was kind of like a tablet
essentially
but they were still like kind of
throwing them into people's yards as
though it was an actual newspaper oh i
thought it was uh it had paper
i don't well it was hard to tell like i
said they were still throwing the
newspaper into the yard like they would
have back in the old days but when you
saw somebody like reading a paper it was
moving around like it was a tablet yeah
i mean it was it what it was is it was
paper was a screen it had its own
it was thin it's a thin and as cheap as
a piece of paper but it was a flexible
screen because remember all the damn
cereal boxes
moved and had their own audio
yeah cause i was like wow that would get
old yeah
because i remember at the time they were
saying that well eventually screens and
computer chips will be cheaper than a
piece of paper is today and you'll see
those everywhere you know the people
will be moving and stuff so that's what
that's what's what picked him up on that
but
it's a cool flick i liked it i enjoyed
it i i understand why tom cruise uh
uh demanded to be in it
because it's got [ __ ] tom cruise
using his ot powers and using his
[ __ ] superior [ __ ] technological
prowess to catch bad guys then it turns
out he's a bad guy that he's working for
the bad guys
and uh
then it starts going in where almost
almost kind of like some it's almost
kind of like a tail that l ron hubbard
would come up with when you think about
it not quite as good
you know because this is actually
dicks this is phillips
philip k dick stories and we were
watching this and i was going like man
they're doing a lot of shout outs to
blade runner with the lighting and stuff
and it turns out later on in the credits
it was a philip k dick story so i was
like going like oh okay that's why they
did a lot of blade runner [ __ ] in it
yeah the story for this actually the
philip k dick story uh which was called
the minority report came out back in the
50s like 1956 and it's actually like a
pretty short story
and i haven't read the short story but i
did read a synopsis of it
the kind of overarching uh you know
theme of the movie as in you know there
are psychics called precogs that can
uh you know tell the future and actually
in the story it's all crime in the movie
it's just murder i'm not really sure why
because i guess they thought that they
would make that less complicated um but
in the short story
i kind of feel like that's like a lot
simpler there's a lot of stuff going on
in the short story that they didn't
really do in the movie
but
it's funny like i said i had totally
forgotten i think i saw this movie back
in like the
maybe a year or two after it came out i
think somebody loaned it to me and i
watched it and i remember like liking it
pretty you know pretty well it's like
i'm not a huge tom cruise fan and i
don't usually love these types of movies
so i remember like being pretty good but
we were scrolling through amazon prime
last night and i was like oh look
minority report is on free to me
so let's just watch that so we can talk
about it tomorrow because i kind of
remembered some [ __ ] about it but i
didn't i don't actually remember if i
sat through the whole uh movie before
and actually it's it was um way better
than i remembered yeah it's good i liked
it yeah i didn't realize it was a um
a steven spielberg movie it does not
have that spielbergy and 80s middle
class america vibe to it it's
it's futuristic and somebody was saying
that it reminded them of fifth element i
had to disagree it's very different from
philip element what it reminded me of
was actually irobot
remember yeah but this is a lot better
than i robot yeah robot was kind of
terrible yeah
but visually it reminded me of irobot a
little bit although irobot wasn't
terrible
it's just uh
it didn't
it just wasn't it wasn't that good um
another one this reminds me of a little
bit
is uh the last true arnold
schwarzenegger movie and that was um
uh what was it called uh
the one where they were reprogramming
people through the eyes and doing all
the genetic engineering what was the
[ __ ] name of that one
somebody in the comment sections might
remember it i have it i just can't
remember i wanted i want to say eraser
but it's not a racer that one was that
was a real shitty one
you guys remember what what movie it is
i'm thinking of on the cover it's got
arnold schwarzenegger with his eyes
peeled back and they're doing something
shooting something in his eye
no not so
rico yeah that was an old one well
interested what i was gonna say was that
um
i think from what i could determine
that
at least as far as the original stories
went
um
this story philip k dick's uh minority
report and the story that he wrote that
total recall was based on we can
remember it for you wholesale were
supposed to be taking place in the same
world
and when this movie was still was like
making the rounds of like when they were
trying to get it made um actually it's
they first conceived it as being a sort
of sequel or in the same universe as the
total recall movie you know what i'm
saying it's supposed to be set like at
the same time period in in the same
universe um but that kind of didn't end
up happening although i guess you could
sort of say it was sort of kind of in
the same universe interestingly i was
just watching
a review of this or kind of like it
wasn't so much a review but like an
explained type of thing where the dude
was
coming up with the idea
and i kind of like this idea i hadn't
actually thought about it when i was
watching the movie
but
his theory
is that everything you see in the movie
after tom cruise's character john
anderson gets haloed as in he gets
brought in and they put the halo on like
he gets arrested for the murder right
everything you see after that point in
the movie is actually his
dream or his hallucination because
that's what they do like when they
arrest you and they put the halo on you
right they put you in the in the you
know deep freeze thing or in the vault
or whatever and you just like have
dreams
for the rest of your
life or the rest of your sentence or
whatever
so
he was pointing out like why he thought
that everything like so that the entire
end of the movie was actually like his
imagination yeah you know what i'm
saying yeah khan he he remembered it was
called sixth day the sixth day oh okay i
think i saw that yeah this movie kind of
reminds me of the sixth day um but sixth
day of course is
it's an arnold schwarzenegger old school
honor sports egg movie probably around
the same time 2002 2004 around that time
but if you like this one c6 day it's
good too
in a similar vein about genetic
engineering that was the last great
arnold schwarzenegger movie
well some people
he also appeared in some damn what was
the name of the [ __ ] uh
the uh with all the mercenaries [ __ ] man
i don't know why
why do you keep bringing my stuff up if
you can't remember if i can't remember
that you're not even talking about this
movie you're talking about other movies
okay
[Laughter]
jenny's trying to keep me in line about
what i'm talking about well because you
keep coming up with all these other
probabilities that you can't you know
like you can't
remind me i was saying which this one
reminded me of it reminded me of
of the sixth day and i robot a lot but
better
better yeah much better i mean you can
tell definitely this was
spielberg yeah spielberg film equality
uh thing because he really did
when he was like talking about adapting
this like i said it's a lot different
than the original short story like the
you know the overarching like theme of
the precogs and every pre-crime and
everything that's the same but a lot of
the other [ __ ] is different
but he actually brought in like a whole
team of consultants
um you know like computer techs and like
architecture people and like all this
other kind of stuff because he wanted to
create
a future that was still like believable
you know what i'm saying and some of the
[ __ ] that that was in this movie like
swiping
like for you know from 2002 um that
wasn't a thing in 2002. so that was
actually something they did predict like
facial recognition targeted marketing
like targeted advertising stuff like
that so there was some stuff in there
that was you know that was accurate even
though we're like cities
even though we were like well they
wouldn't they don't still have malls
really um and they don't really still
have like newspapers in the sense that
right
where they just like throw it in
somebody's yard
they did not show anything having to do
with social media or actual
they did not understand the impact of
what social media and the internet would
do well a lot of sci-fi movies didn't
though to be fair it was something that
kind of blindsided the mainstream people
they didn't realize how much that would
get in the way of the old-fashioned
traditional economy
those people are all obsolete now
you know
i mean
a [ __ ] shopping mall has to be
something very high-tech and very
expensive in order to survive nowadays
grampur's hammer said when tom cruise
ate the rotten sandwich in the fridge
yeah i know i was like man that was so
[ __ ] gross why was that even in there
for some reason like when i saw him why
was that in there because it was badass
no i mean when i first saw the when i
saw that scene you know and the guy like
that had taken out his eyeballs and
popped in the new ones he put the
sandwich like a good sandwich in there
yeah and then but there was like still
rotten ones in there and i was just kind
of like wait a minute does that mean
that tom cruise has been there longer
than he thought or that this isn't the
first time that he's done this to
somebody and he just never bothers like
taking the old sandwiches out of the
refrigerator yeah
i don't think the doctor did that the
girlfriend did that it just they were
kind of trashy [ __ ] junkies you know
and
she was grabbing his ass she liked him
but she was just so trashy she didn't
ever bother cleaning out the
refrigerator and that's what would
happen if in a dirty refrigerator i had
kind of forgotten how much because i
remembered like i said i saw this movie
probably like in 2003 or 2004 and i had
remembered it being like very very
serious which most of it is but there
are some like funny like almost i would
almost go like shading over into goofy
kind of stuff yeah like it did have some
comedy like the like the one scene where
you know they're trying to catch tom
cruise and like they have the jet packs
and then they like bust into that those
people's apartment and like the back of
the jet pack like cooks the woman's
hamburgers and stuff like that it's just
like you know there's kind of some kind
of silly [ __ ] in there like yeah but
that's that's okay though i think they
were trying to lighten the mood of the
movie a little bit
because it is kind of like i mean the
whole theme of the movie i guess
being you know free will versus
determinism it's interesting because in
this in the short story uh john aterton
the main character who tom cruise plays
in this is actually like kind of an old
fat bald guy
and um but of course you know they can't
have that in a movie so they have to put
tom cruise in there instead but he um in
the story he was like the commissioner
he was like the big deal guy that
started the whole pre-crime division
whereas in this one he was just kind of
like
he worked for pre-crime and
he had a backstory that made him
really um into the idea because his son
had been kidnapped and presumably
murdered uh so he had reason to want to
prevent crime and like get all on board
with this whole like pre-crime situation
whereas in the
short story he didn't really have a
backstory like that but he was just like
the commissioner and the one that had
kind of like implemented it
um i think in the short story too
it's weird because um i think in the
short story it was like post-apocalyptic
or like post-nuclear war type [ __ ] too
you're right well that's
then that's would have been like um do
androids dream of electric shield yeah
that's what i mean it's kind of it's the
same yeah they're kind of all in the
same kind of like after ecological
[ __ ] apocalypses and stuff all of
them
yeah so this one was no exception but
they i feel like they didn't really do
that um in the movie in the movie it
just seemed like it was all high tech
everything was high tech and it was just
kind of like
well not everything though when you
think about it because remember the
first guy that they caught he was living
in a normal apartment
well that was one thing and steven
spielberg had said that this was one
thing and why he got all these people
together he said because i wanted this
to be a grounded believable future i
don't want everything to be like super
high tech because that's not the way
[ __ ] works it's like everything doesn't
progress at the same time yeah so he's
like some places like you know in
washington dc and georgetown and stuff
like that looked just the same because
they probably would you know some of
those houses are over 100 years old so
that means the house can stand for over
100 years that's what he was saying so
he's like so i wanted it to be like
believe so he did actually like really
think all of that through and get like
all these consultants in there because
he wanted he wanted it to look like a
very lived-in
sort of huge like not not super super
sleek and there's still like remnants of
stuff that we would recognize john cruz
department was all high tech his [ __ ]
electric car
would stick to the side of the wall and
go up and
meet with the side of his apartment and
he'd walk out it was all super high-tech
but it was dirty he was doing drugs in
it smoking future crack
i like that they made him like a drug
addict yeah he's drug it and i like that
they made him kind of like a [ __ ] up
sort of character yeah because well
because i think that's good because that
gave him like an arc because like i said
it's based on a short story and the
short story is like very short so it
doesn't really give a backstory as to
why this character would want this
pre-crime thing why it's it's kind of
like the short story was kind of like
examining a different thing yeah so i
like that they gave him this big long
that would give him a reason like to
want to implement this program yeah but
i was noticing that everything in the
movie though
uh it conformed to uh scientology's
[ __ ] gnosticism
it all did the idea of will
willpower actually ruling
um the individual willpower um
technology um
and then uh yeah the drug addiction
thing was an aspect of me remember how
they were bigger than narcan
yeah all that [ __ ] would have [ __ ]
played right into and then the idea of
psychic abilities alongside with
merged in with high-tech
technology all right that's that's right
there with [ __ ] scientology
right there with it you know what's
interesting about this though is that
even though
the type they didn't change the title
because normally when they adapt philip
k dick's stuff they changed the title
they didn't change the title of this the
minority report is the actual title of
the short story but the weird thing
about it is that in the original short
story
you know if if you haven't seen the
movie or read the um or read the story
like what a minority report is is that
there are three precogs and sometimes
every now and then one of them has like
a dissenting
vision uh you know showing like a
another alternate another possible
future and um that's called the minority
report now in the short story
that's kind of like you know the the
fact of him discovering that there is a
minority report on a particular crime is
a thing that kind of makes everybody
like question the whole system whereas
in this one they find out about the
minority report thing but that's not
what it almost turns out to be like not
important or like a red herring type of
thing because it doesn't play into yeah
it doesn't play into freeing him
yeah of the crimes what what plays into
it is the whole concept of the echo
yeah you know where where the where
sometimes the the psychics have like
echoing visions of like they see the
same murder over and over again and the
techs know not to look for that because
they're like oh they're just seeing it
again that's just an echo of [ __ ] that
already happened or was already
prevented um and the fact of like
the main dude like the main bad guy max
von sydow yeah knowing that that's a
thing and like using that to commit a
murder knowing that you know that it was
so he gets in so really what the the
villain is government corruption that's
really what that's the main factor
think about it yeah government
corruption caused the whole thing
which that's very scientology
i think it's interesting too that
it's almost kind of like because like i
said they kind of explore in this movie
a lot of the whole you know is the
future predetermined
you know and
making pre-crime like it you know that's
gonna happen this person's gonna murder
this person or whatever
but then like the fact that it's not you
know exactly the way they thought and
they kind of explore that but then
i don't know it's kind of like a thing
where
it
in the universe of the movie it's almost
kind of like the only people that have
free will
in the in the sense that we're talking
about is people that are that know the
visions you know what i mean the fact
that you know max von sydow the facts
the fact that tom cruise's character the
fact that they've seen the visions
so they know what the future is going to
be so they can change it
if you didn't work for the police you
know commissioner you didn't work for
the pre-crime unit and you didn't know
what the vision was going to happen
yeah you that's the that's the thing and
actually mike's now inside out wasn't
part of the government more like a
government contractor they hadn't fully
merged with the government yet had they
well yeah and i think that was a good
that was a good thing to do because i
think in the short story um it was
already it had already been implemented
everywhere whereas in this it was just
in dc and it was almost kind of like a
pilot program yeah and what another
thing that's funny is that they just
kind of gloss over that this is done by
decree
remember when they were [ __ ] when
they were arresting people by decree of
something or other below a free crime it
was just a decree what hadn't been it
hadn't been adjudicated
or authenticated by us by by the senate
or anything like that it was just done
by decree
thank you victor what do you say i'm
gonna miss wednesday and friday's shows
have some future money well thank you
very much
yeah i got a couple shout outs too but
i'll wait till the end to do those but
um which i that that goes back into the
into the blade runner uh blade runner
and the ridley scott version of the
future
where
governments are basically held captive
by corporations that corporations are
decreeing what should happen and telling
governments what they should be doing
because everything's subbed out which is
kind of ahead of its time that was going
on for a long time though that that
really started in the 40s
but the well the thing about it though
is that in this movie like i said it's
just in dc
and it seems like it's isn't there like
because there's an ad at the beginning
where there's like a politician or
something like that who's running and
it's saying you know vote yes on this
whatever so it's you know people are
still voting on whether they want this
or not but the fact that the department
of justice sends colin farrell's
character
um you know whitwer to dc to kind of
like oversee this program and he's not
really like on board with it and he's
kind of in there to look at it to see if
this is something that we want to um you
know implement nationwide i think that
was a good from a storytelling
standpoint i think that's a good
uh kind of way of coming into the world
because you're bringing him into the
program and he doesn't really know how
it works so he has to have like
you know tom cruise explain it to him so
they don't have to like set it all up in
a really clunky
by the time this is happening they
already have was it tens of thousands of
people
in pre-crime prison yeah which are kind
of like in suspended animation
yeah they just put the thing on them and
like give them
you know hallucinations
or whatever yeah i guess they're
pleasant hallucinations you're just in
that [ __ ] you never come back out are
they pleasant
they show they show what they're seeing
and it seems like they're just kind of
replaying
things from their past over and over
again yeah didn't say whether or not
they age
maybe they do age they might just you
might just stay in there in a fantasy
until you die but they got them all
stacked up
yeah like in a vault like in a vault
in the end of the movie of course when
all this [ __ ] falls through they're all
pardoned because they didn't commit any
crime
they were just going to
most of them some of them i guess did
but
um
actually
no
had any of them
actually committed a crime they showed
some people getting
drowned
so yeah that one guy killed that woman
by drowning her so he was in there
but he was one of the early ones
remember no what ended up happening with
that he didn't actually kill her okay
then he was hired by max monsignor
to do it but he was knowing that he
would be caught before he killed her
and then max von saido stepped in after
they took that fall guy away so that guy
didn't kill anybody either but he was
going to the max von sydow killed that's
right her that's right but the reason
that he set that up was
because so he could kill her and make it
look like an echo so in that private
prison nobody had killed anybody
no
they were just supposedly going to yeah
that's a trip when you think about it
they'd love to do that
well and and but that's the thing about
this kind of story is that it really
does kind of go into
you know
could that ever be infallible no it
couldn't because obviously you know
just because humans can game a system
any system yeah and that's what they're
saying and honestly like i kind of like
it's not so much just the
i like that they expanded the story out
where whereas before it was just like
the minority report like one of the
psychics visions didn't agree with the
other two and which they had that in the
movie but i also like that they
expanded it out to
um to that echo thing because if the
psychics really did have echoes like
they kept seeing repeated echoes of a
murder that had already happened or
already been prevented let's say um then
and you knew about it then you could
totally game that system and that's
exactly what uh what burgess did um max
bonsaito's character and because he knew
that it was gonna happen or he you know
he could set the whole thing up you
could just hire somebody and look at as
long as it was close enough they would
just like think it was an echo so i
think that was like a really good
and you know and it just went to show
that
the system could never be in fact a
system like that could never be
infallible uh because you don't know
you know just because like three
psychics who are supposedly never wrong
like saw some [ __ ] but as i said they
even like if if you worked for the
police thing and like saw the visions
well then you knew would know what was
going to happen and you could change
[ __ ] well that's what the thing is
that's what scientologists do yeah when
they're moving backwards and forwards
through the whole track remember once
they get to what is ot ot-11 or ot8
they now have control over the
space-time continuum yeah that's how tom
cruise never gets hurt
if he stubs his toe he just goes
backwards in time and doesn't stub his
toe so therefore he doesn't stub his toe
if anything [ __ ] up happens he goes
wait a minute hold on how come i didn't
go back in time and fix that something's
wrong and then he goes and pays
scientology more money to go through
[ __ ] auditing to remove a thetan that
prevented him from going back in time
and and
and not stubbing his toe it's great when
you think about it so in a way
the pre-crime thing it's it's a
scientology power
it is kind of like i can see why tom
cruise wanted to be in this movie
yeah remember they said it was happening
in a temple and they were kind of like
the priests and they were reading the
oracles
yeah it could be that the meet tom
cruise's take on the meaning of the
movie is that the reason why pre-crime
failed is because it wasn't scientology
running it if it was church of
scientology the [ __ ] would have worked
yeah maybe
[Laughter]
those are scientology powers yeah well i
think
those are ot powers
that that the precogs had yeah
definitely
it's an interesting thing too because i
kind of feel like this is maybe like a
little bit you know since you brought up
the precogs this is a little bit of
something that
is another thing that they kind of i
don't know if i'd say they gloss over
because they do bring it up a couple of
times um the pre-cogs themselves in the
short story they were like kind of
deformed and
uh you know really gross looking and
everything and uh but in this one they
were just like normal people and it's
almost kind of like
that was another like secondary thing
that they were talking about it's like
can can you ever justify like taking
these human beings and like subjecting
them to this kind of life where they're
just like laying there in this pond all
the time and they're just like working
for you all the time because in the
movie at least and i think even tom
cruise says like very near the beginning
when he's explaining to uh to whit
whatever that dude's name is that it's
like well it helps if you don't think of
them as human yeah but they are human
yeah but that's what they did in greco
roman oracles yeah they'd have them
girls [ __ ] all the all day long over
the damn [ __ ] gas vents coming out of
the damn volcanic ground you know about
that they'd be [ __ ] high as hell yeah
yeah give them [ __ ] oracle [ __ ] then
they die though and they said well we
had to put a new one in there
imagine that yep yeah so
that's what they're talking about
grantham's hammer said if murderous
thoughts were arrestable offenses
prisons would be full of people who yeah
whoever every like every person that
ever had a bad boss it wasn't the
thoughts though they're actually seeing
the murder happen in the future getting
pictures of it
through the minds of these
so evidently they
they had proof that
that the murder did take place in
another timeline but it was prevented
that's what they're that's what that's
what the whole thing was about they
weren't just thinking about it they had
to do it
just thinking about it wouldn't cause
the precogs to see it
because one of the best honestly i had
kind of forgotten about this little
scene but when i was watching a review
of it and they showed it again i was
like oh yeah that was really great
there was a scene after tom cruise um
you know gets brought up in one of the
visions that he killed somebody um
there's a scene where he kind of runs
away and then he comes back and he
confronts um whitwer in the elevator and
he pulls a gun on whitware and you can
tell that whitware is like not afraid
that he's gonna shoot him because he
hasn't seen it like on the he's like oh
well you know there's there's no red
ball they call it a red ball it's like a
crime precaution
yeah so he's like standing there like
whatever but then an alarm goes off like
in the other part of the building which
means that a red ball is it and then you
can see like the look in his eyes go oh
[ __ ] cause like he realizes that what if
that's me like what if he actually is
gonna blow my head off but it's like i
had forgotten about that little scene
but that was like a great the precoc saw
tom cruise killing the guy in the future
and then when and he's going i don't
even know that dude i'm not gonna kill
him and then once this once he actually
meets up with the dude and finds out
what the situation is he almost kills
him but he because of tom cruise's
superior [ __ ] ot powers he resists it
and doesn't kill him and then that guy
gets pissed and grabs the gun and pulls
it and makes him kill him yeah i don't
know if it was the exact if it was the
exact same
murder that the precog saw
i don't think it was no because in the
vision in the vision he's shooting from
him from far away and he says like
something like goodbye whatever that is
it didn't make a difference it didn't
make a difference though because the
whole thing was a setup and they needed
him to kill somebody so they could get
rid of him basically
and the whole thing that they were
covering up like i said in the story it
was much more um like a simple kind of
yes he was being set up he was actually
being set up by whitwer in the story
which they kind of do that in the movie
like you're led to believe that the
department of justice dude is a bad guy
because he's very antagonistic when he
first comes there because he doesn't
believe that the system is infallible
but he actually turns out to be right in
the end so he actually ends up and he
actually ends up after he figures out
um you know what ended up happening with
anderton and the murder and everything
like that he actually does think oh
maybe anderton was set up and then like
he tries to help him so you know and
then it's revealed later that like max
von cider was actually like the bad guy
the whole time even though he was all
nice and grandfatherly but um yeah so i
kind of like that they
sort of took the story and then kind of
like misled you
about the way it was going but like i
said i don't know
i saw the review this one review like i
said where
the guy was theorizing
that everything you saw like the end of
the movie
after tom cruise gets haloed gets like
put in the vault
after the arrest that everything you see
after that is just his
imagination or his dream of what
happened a lot of total recall yeah well
like i said these were originally
supposed to have taken place in the same
universe and i will note that the short
story um ended with it didn't have a
happy ending it ended with the pre-crime
system like
continuing yeah you know what i mean so
um
so i don't know i i know that steven
spielberg is kind of like you know he
likes happy endings and stuff but
his later stuff was a lot more
complex i guess so i could see maybe
that
maybe you could do that because the the
dude in the video pointed out he's like
there's a couple things
that happened you know in the end part
of the you know after tom cruise gets
arrested
that didn't really make a lot of sense
from a plot point of view like where did
his wife get his eyeball from
yeah um you know where you know why
would why would burgess have left the
gun there for her to pick up you know
why there's like all this stuff that you
know
would they really have gotten back
together or she gets all pregnant at the
end and stuff like that it's like so
maybe this was just how you know maybe
tom cruise never did get out of jail and
he was just like in there and this was
how he was imagining [ __ ] worked out and
then the whole system was dismantled and
all the prisoners were set free
it's i don't know it's kind of
interesting i didn't think of that when
i was watching it but then i saw
somebody's theory and i was like oh well
you know that that could be and like i
said especially since the whole thing
tied in with total recall
where
everything was just like you're not
really sure like which is reality and
which isn't
it's a decent flip
yeah it's a decent flick and it kind of
fits in with
that universe the total recall universe
also kind of like the sixth day and
uh you know
just blade runner
it's decent i liked it it's better than
i remembered it yeah it's it doesn't i'm
not you know what i'm not um i
understand like why
it was um visually shot the way it was
like it was over like uh over bleached
like a lot of the shots were like super
white white and blue and stuff like that
um which was a deliberate choice uh
which is fine i'm not a fan of it i
think it was a little bit ugly but i can
see why they did it though that was
really in vogue at the time for high
tech it was yeah we're trying to give
that tech look to things yeah
it's just it was just that era yeah yeah
i know but yeah
and and like i said just the way they
shot it was a deliberate choice which
like i said that's fair enough i didn't
care for it i thought it was kind of
ugly it's kind of kind of a modified
version of the matrix matrix was all
kind of black and green kind of tinge
you know what i mean and like like
everything was kind of through a
greenish filter they just did it blue
later it's like it was like they like
technology had advanced somehow yeah
everything has to be like that's not
blue and sleek yeah i kind of feel like
in the 90s and the 2000s everything was
either blue tinted or orange tinted yeah
like depending on what kind of movie it
was but it was uh yeah it was just all
that kind of thing but yeah it was just
i i really kind of i
i you know i i'm not like a humongous
fan of movies like this like these big
kind of epic sci-fi movies that are like
really slick and everything but this
movie actually was a lot better
than i remembered and the story was a
lot more complex than i remembered um
especially considering
you know how simple i don't want to say
that the story the original story was
simple but i like all the stuff that
they added to it you know what i mean to
like give it a richer backstory and like
kind of change it a little bit from the
story i say the movie has aged well it
has not from a technological standpoint
but from a storytelling standpoint it's
aged well tom cruise looked good in it
he was probably in his late 30s mid 30s
at that time
it's funny when you look at his
physicality you could tell he's working
out you could tell he's doing possibly a
little bit of pd peds
but i didn't realize that
that tom has such narrow shoulders he's
got narrow shoulders for a guy
another thing that i liked about the
movie is that they didn't hide the fact
that he's much shorter than other people
in this
yeah they didn't at least try to make
him like look bigger than everybody else
yeah you know
in another story in other movies they
really try to [ __ ]
give down play that yeah give the
illusion that he's the same size and or
as big as everybody else that he's kind
of a big guy he's a little bitty guy you
know actually it's a little bit he's
about five six probably
although they'll never claim that
they'll claim that he's five ten
yeah well no he's five six
it's just i mean there wasn't too much
like you said um you know the first
scene where they kind of show him doing
his stuff you know with the sliding
thing where he's doing this that and the
other thing you can tell
and this is one of the reasons why i
always have like trouble watching like
tom cruise movies because he always just
comes across as like just that little
bit like super cocky
look how awesome i
yeah check am
out he's all serious and everything yeah
yeah um so it's like that just kind of
like funny to me and there are some kind
of things uh in the movie where people
talk about man he's the best and this
and that and the other yeah but it
wasn't too egregious in this one and
actually there was like a lot there was
so much going on in this and
just
you know the philosophical questions it
raises are like so interesting and i
honestly i didn't even realize this
movie's like two and a half hours long
because it really didn't seem all that
long ago
it moves quickly it kind of like just
flew by yeah um you know that like i
said there are a couple of like you know
like the jet pack fight and like the
whole thing where he goes and he gets
like sealed in the car and all that
other kind of stuff which is kind of
like which is like a little bit goofy
but you know no tom's got another sci-fi
movie that i also liked i want to see
this one again too actually i think i
have it i have it on blu-ray it's called
oblivion yeah that was a good one
actually i i really like that one i
haven't i've only seen it twice i want
to see that one again i want to
reanalyze that one oblivion
based on memory is even higher end than
this one visually it had a really good
uh but this one man the story is really
good and and it's it's like other
you know
dicks type movies you know what i mean
like
[ __ ]
blade runner type stuff and you know
[ __ ] what was the other one that
totally recall yeah it's like that so
it's good it's good a lot of philip k
dick's stuff has been uh adapted so i
want to take a look at take a look at
oblivion again
i remember really enjoying that
and he's got another sci-fi with his
version of war of the worlds
which i've seen several times i don't
love that it's
i remember visually it was really good
but
it stuck it stuck to the original story
of war the world's pretty closely maybe
a little bit too closely in certain ways
but then it
diverged in others like they weren't
from another planet
per se they were from deep underneath
the earth which i thought was [ __ ]
corny
oh they've been waiting down there for
millions of years
and uh
it'd have been better to have them come
from another planet maybe they were
underneath the surface of mars that
would have made a lot more sense that
they were underneath the surface of mars
for millions of years and now they're
ready to come out
and and that way you could have the
whole
um h.g wells element of the story where
you know the astronomers are seeing them
launch from underneath the surface and
you see in the ships common and
everything
because that
you know that part of the the original
well story built up a lot of suspense
yeah that they're coming you can see
them coming yeah you know
and then they're trying to make peace
with them when they show up then they
get annihilated you know
it's looking
that's where that in the whole of trying
to make peace with them and getting
annihilated is where the 50s version
of war of the worlds got it right
whether they send the priest down there
i'm going to talk to them they're god's
creatures and then that [ __ ]
they [ __ ] annihilate the priest
nothing but just a shadow left on the
ground of him yeah that was pretty cool
yeah i was going to ask about yeah cause
xanada was saying about the man in the
high castle which i actually haven't
seen i haven't read the book either but
yeah i knew that they had made like a
adaptation of it it was like a series
they also did a series of this um
you know a minority report series i
think it started in 2014
and ran for a season or two um but i
don't know i heard it was okay but i
haven't seen it either
um and then gram thirst was asking if
there were any philip k dick stories
that haven't been made into a movie yet
i'm sure there are a couple but a lot of
his [ __ ] has been adapted somebody asked
about dark city um i definitely want to
do that one of these days because i
really really like that movie
somebody also brought up uh dragged
across concrete which is on my list to
do as well uh and take shelter which is
also on my list i just haven't got
around to it yet so okay so we had a
couple shout outs to you i wanted to
save them till the end right so
yesterday after we uh streamed
or wait no we didn't stream yesterday
but yesterday yesterday afternoon we got
a little package yeah last night and in
it it was from sergeant rocco
and there was some uh chocolates in
there because remember on wednesday
night show he said he was going to send
us some buckeyes yeah i said i had never
heard of that like chocolate and peanut
butter yeah and man they're pretty damn
good kind of like a real soft creamy
version of a reese's peanut butter cups
yeah and they came they were a little
bit melted but a couple of them were
melted on the sides but the ones in the
middle were that's because they didn't
they when they dropped them off they
didn't tell me they were on the front
porch yeah i just had to find them out
there because they had ice packs in
there like or dry ice there's like dry
ice in there but it had already kind of
uh
the dry ice had already gotten weak it
wasn't cold when you got them out of
there was it no yeah yeah it's hot here
y'all it's hot
but like i said i think really the only
ones the ones on the side were like a
little bit melted yeah they weren't that
bad but um they weren't round they kind
of went a little more
but you know they're like i said put
them in the refrigerator and they're
hardened back up yeah they're so they're
still good also uh wanted to say too got
this yeah look at that from b's nest
business got that in mexico look how
[ __ ] cool do you turn it so they can
see it oh my god that's so awesome yeah
de los muertos yeah it's good
and like a dude you can tell that
[ __ ] you can tell that bees nest is a
man [ __ ] left the price tag on
it
he does something
oh yeah thought about that
dudes don't think about anything
i don't know what that what it is that
they are thinking about yeah but oh and
also remember a long time ago
i said that i was working on a halloween
board game
and i said oh my god i only have a
couple things so you finish it and stuff
like that guess what it's [ __ ] done
and i have i just got the proof copy of
it yesterday which means i just a couple
hours ago put it for sale it's kind of
expensive because there's a lot of [ __ ]
in here because it's got lots of cards
and little pumpkins and all kind of
stuff but that's what it is right there
that's a new game show them to back and
it's a new game that i made it's a board
game it's got a big huge ass board
and it's all halloween like little
halloween costumes and [ __ ] like that
it's super cool
yeah so there it is it's on the game
crafter i'll probably put a there's a
link to the game crafter thing in there
but i just put it up for sale today
because i just got that yesterday and i
looked through all the
stuff to make sure it all looked good
and uh you know and it looks good i have
a couple more that i have my absinthe
one and my ancient egyptian one and i
also i ordered proof copies of those too
but i have to wait for the proof copies
to come and i have to look at all the
[ __ ] to make sure it's right uh before i
can put them up for sale and then i
think all the games
that i had up there will be
available
and then eventually i wanted to i still
want to do like a horror trivia game one
of these days and i definitely want to
do one that's like i wanted to do one
like a german expressionist type of
look or type of theme to it but i don't
know what the game's going to be yet
that's probably going to be next year
though but um yeah but i finally got all
the ones that i had up there like kind
of done and
ordered so i could look at the proofs so
you know
uh rest of the message got to cut off
jenny oh want to say your hair looks
awesome today well thank you very much i
just uh
just shaved it earlier today because
probably i think tonight we're going to
go out right yeah yeah that's right
because tomorrow's labor day so they're
doing like a special yeah i think it's
kind of like memento mori but it's kind
of i think it's like a couple different
djs all right i think as far as i'm uh
aware but yeah they're doing like a
special one tonight because tomorrow's a
holiday so we're gonna go out tonight so
we didn't go out last night that's why
we watched so many movies now tomorrow
we're going to be talking about
fire in the sky yeah the movie the movie
about travis walton yeah we saw we
watched that on last night too because
we were scrolling through amazon prime
and i was like oh yeah and it's weird
because remember we did the show about
travis walton yeah and i could have
sworn that i watched fire in the sky
before we did that show but like then we
started watching the movie and i'm like
you know what i don't think i [ __ ]
seen this movie like i've seen scenes
from it like you know the alien
abduction and everything like that but
it's like i don't i don't think i'd ever
sat and watched the whole thing and i'd
forgotten like how star-studded the cast
was and yeah it's better than i
remembered it yeah it just you know it's
just the the abduction scenes of what
the aliens did or do not fit
what travis walton said and i don't
think travis walton was real um happy
with that
angle of the movie they definitely tried
to take it in the direction of like
alien one or alien two
real [ __ ] slimy organic [ __ ] ships
and everything that's not what he said
yeah i was like clean up your ship
aliens god that's not what it was it's
so goopy
[Laughter]
i like travis walton's uh uh story about
what happened when he got abducted you
know but maybe like well i don't know i
guess we'll talk about that tomorrow too
but it's kind of like maybe that
wouldn't have made like as good a movie
well it's because it wasn't that
believable what he said well the [ __ ]
that's in this movie isn't all that i
believe we believe yeah it's even less
believable right
but like no it was a weird case i think
all that [ __ ] was just uh recovered
memories from hypnosis because when they
first found him he couldn't remember
what happened yeah that's the truth i
don't think you well i just it's kind of
like remember we talked about this a lot
on our satanic panic shows where it's
just kind of like there was a subset of
uh therapists and stuff like that that
were hypnotizing people and like maybe
uh deliberately or not uh giving people
suggestions and leading them down to
certain kinds these are the same people
that got little kids to say that they
were abducted by satanic cults and
flushed down the toilets into secret
rooms and then they're chuck norris yeah
with chuck norris
and that the the satanists all escaped
in a balloon and just [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] like that look you can get kids to
say anything
well yeah they're very imaginative yeah
beowulf asked what was our favorite part
in minority report
i you know what i quite liked the
opening sequence where they were um the
whole thing where they were setting up
where that one guy was like gonna kill
his wife and and the lover because i
like that that was
i like that it set up the whole concept
of pre-crime and everything like that
without really explaining it like it
just kind of showed it so i thought that
was really well done and i liked a lot
of the um
the vision sequences now the the woman
that played anne lively in and you only
see her really in the visions was that
not jessica harper i'm pretty sure that
was jessica harper in case you don't
know who that is she was in phantom of
the paradise and the original suspiria
among many other things she was also in
the superior remake uh briefly
but i
could have sworn that was her but i
don't know if it was my favorite part is
when uh he got his eyes swapped out
that was also a really good yeah like
when he that whole time when he was in
that like scuzzy ass apartment and that
dude was like real yeah
like he had the timer and [ __ ]
that was a very good sequence he's
getting ready to change his eyes you
locked me up
and i'd be like [ __ ] oh maybe i should
find another eye replacement
eye replacement technician yeah
i'm sure they're a dime a dozen in the
future well i guess well there was like
a big black market and like getting your
eyes swapped out right because
everything was like uh was done through
your eyeballs so yeah all right so uh i
liked the spooky plants uh sandra yeah
that was a weird that was a weird scene
genetically engineered plants i guess
yeah with all the because you know of
course
uh google says that was jessica harper
see okay i was right i know i recognized
her i was like that looks just like
jessica harper yeah all right so uh yeah
so tomorrow we'll be back talking about
hopefully we won't be too hungover and
we'll be talking about uh
fire in the sky so thanks everybody for
dropping by we'll see you guys tomorrow
afternoon